hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
i ah just check it in are you what's
going on how are you there's some happy
people out there there's some sad people
out there was a wonderful couple of days
of soccer here the World Cup France
oho beats Belgium and England Falls to
Croatia it's coming home it's coming
home I finally looked at up to see like
why do they keep saying that it's coming
home you know
I immediately assume like well obviously
England must have won the most
championships and this is their arrogant
[ __ ] way of being like yeah this is
where it rightfully belongs kind of like
when the Yankees win a World Series and
then all those [ __ ] talking heads on
on ESPN will go and everything is all is
right in baseball again it's white why
because at orded million dollar team on
a [ __ ] playoff series turns out
that's not what it is
evidently the game of soccer now this
might our football footy whatever the
[ __ ] you call it evidently it was
according to the English it was created
in England they were the ones who
decided to spite the fact that you have
four limbs you can only use two they
wanted a degree of difficulty they
weren't like the animals over here you
know will we get bored and like pick it
up you know
tackle up which meant jump on his back
and throw him to the [ __ ] ground ah
now tackle over there's you trip
somebody you take your foot out your
triple so evidently it started over
there that's what this saying so that's
what it meant because I thought it meant
that they had the most championships and
then I looked up all-time World Cup
champions alright what you gotta do how
the [ __ ] do you not to do I don't give a
[ __ ] what the sport is I wanna know who
dominated turns out Brazil
since 1930 they won the most they've won
558 60 to 70 94 in 2002 which is a
[ __ ] lot considering it's every four
years I mean that been Oh 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 20 this is a 21st
one and they've won 21 like whatever
they [ __ ] was that twenty percent of
twenty five percent of them then Germany
won't yeah they they got four Italy has
four oh they should have had five and
ninety four I remember that one
Argentina hand to God that guy whatever
his name was the hell was that guy's
name Diego or some [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
was his name I used to know his name and
one of those [ __ ] names was just like
you the second they gave him that his
name it's just like [ __ ] is gonna be
raining down on this guy right
I forget hand a god guy that guy it was
weird he was like in shape and he also
looked fat what the [ __ ] was his name
Diego arigato was something like that I
can't [ __ ] remember
then I got my hope I say this right I
always always uruguay uruguay wanted
twice and then england france and spain
of all what at once that's interesting
because I thought Spain was a powerhouse
and I would have thought in England when
a bunch way back in the day when it's
probably just a bunch of white guys
running around right yeah I also don't
so that's why they say it's coming home
it's not some arrogant [ __ ] it's like
hey you know this game that the whole
world loves you know not to pat
ourselves on the back but guess what we
came up with it it's our [ __ ] okay
everything you know you know I mean you
know it's not just all about
colonization the caste system and it's
slaving people of other colors around
the world it's not just about that's not
all we did okay yeah
okay but you can't deny that the
beautiful game of football known as
soccer over here in the States
as we sit around eating nabis right was
evidently created in England I don't
know when they did it you think for it
to have a World Cup by 1930 for it to
sweep the [ __ ] nation wait a minute
they also had an empire back then oh I
get it so they came up with this game
they come in they'd [ __ ] take you
over they'd [ __ ] kill a bunch of
people and everyone's like man these
guys are [ __ ] [ __ ] man VI settle
down settle down
we're gonna teach you a little game all
right
you can't use your arms Lauda you had
your arms chopped off because you
couldn't find any gold anyway so this is
gonna work real well for you all I can
use is your feet and your [ __ ] head
and the game spread like wow as England
expanded her empire I never understood
why it was considered female was that to
tone it down that was a bunch of lunatic
guys going around the world going it's a
nice place to live too bad there's other
people here what can we do about this
everybody does it right everybody's done
it since the beginning of time you go
back you go back far enough in history
books this is what all guilty white
people do everybody yeah you know
Africans enslaved other Africans you
know I always say that should try to get
past it you know it's like the Billy
Joel song we didn't start the fire which
has got to be the most classic the most
classic [ __ ] baby boomer response I
mean what a [ __ ] baby
he couldn't even take a little bit of
responsibility you know hey you know
we're eating starving and he starts
naming all his [ __ ] half of it is like
pop stars like Marilyn Monroe what did
she have to do with foreign policy I
know she [ __ ] a couple of Kennedys but
I mean other than that I don't think
that dick
whether or not we went into Cuba Doris
Day [ __ ] imposed it but duppa duppa do
buh-buh-buh-buh trouble in the Suez the
[ __ ] he must have been on blow when he
wrote that song
it's like Billy you're gonna take any
responsibility for this self-centered
[ __ ] that the baby boom generation was
I'm not saying everything it did was bad
I mean he invented the frisbee right was
that you guys it was at the greatest
generation I know somewhere in that
there's got to be truth right from the
greatest generation you know that
generation also didn't want to play
baseball with Jackie Robinson by the way
to the baby boomers who are you know
widely considered the most selfish [ __ ]
you know this country has ever produced
right just sitting around staring at
their navel you know this is the dog
right that's the same generation that
gave us hippies but Julie Bergen stocks
you know [ __ ] in the mud at a concert
I just have a theory way back in the day
you know when they talked about HIV and
AIDS they always said that you know it
was some somebody you know every sorry
someone a monkey or some [ __ ] and some
guy in France got it I never thought it
was and you just see all those naked
white people rolling around [ __ ] each
other in the mud I mean he can't tell me
that something didn't come out of that
you know at least a stronger strain of
the mumps right so anyways to get back
to it you know I was I was working as an
actor I was acting the last couple of
days and I was talking to this dude
going like yeah how come England keeps
saying it's coming home and they were
talking about the World Cup and is that
what they saying those colonizing [ __ ]
like it's [ __ ] dude went off I was
just like you know white people win
we're not all bad I mean there's some
things you know the windows curtains you
know we
some nice things you know now you can
look out your house and see all the lack
of opportunity right right from inside
your house without white people am I
actually taking credit for Windows I
don't know I have no idea I don't read
oh speaking of which oh my god oh my god
I said on my last podcast that the
Obamas bought an 82 million dollar house
turned out it was an eight point one
million dollar house
it wasn't even eight point two million
that's how off I was and this is my
favorite thing so now all these people
like what why don't you do your [ __ ]
homework man like nothing makes people
flip out not even religion unless you
make fun of Muslims then those [ __ ]
lunatics liable to do something but
[ __ ] if you make if you make fun of
like a democrat or republican nothing
brings people out of the woodwork so all
these people like why don't you do your
[ __ ] homework which is less this
whole podcast is based on me not doing
any homework not reading whatsoever so
I'm just gonna tell you you political
[ __ ] up there you got a lot of [ __ ]
nerve Allah I just said aids came for
white people [ __ ] in the mud at
Woodstock are you gonna come back at me
on that one what this whole podcast
exists for one reason and one reason
only it's for to make you feel smarter
ice we here at the Monday morning
podcast and by we I mean me and the
voices in my head that agree with me we
here at the Monday morning podcast set
the bar so low that even you you know
with that college that you went to that
advertised on television and you drove
yourself there and they living there was
not even an option they didn't have
dorms they just you know it was your
College one giant sad building looking
like a high school for people in their
20s yeah yeah that's who you are
and you know what even you get to feel
smart on this podcast
so my favorite thing is if you go back
and you listen to my podcasts on Monday
when I thought I was so [ __ ] right
about the Obama's buying this 82 million
dollar house is somebody actually wrote
into the podcast and goes you know pill
I love you but why don't you do your
homework Obama just signed a sixty-two
million dollar book deal okay and this
is what's [ __ ] hilarious he's telling
me to do my homework he didn't even do
the homework to look up to double check
what the [ __ ] I said even say if it was
true he just took it for granted that I
said eighty two million dollar house and
then he's like he took that his truth
and started looking up the guy's [ __ ]
book deal so why don't you do your
[ __ ] homework man alright for the
nine millionth time okay on this podcast
do not take anything I say seriously
okay you disagree with it away I mean
you can correct me and all that but just
don't get upset and don't be [ __ ]
surprised that I [ __ ] don't read and
then Mike my fax might be off by a good
72 million dollars okay you know you
guys sound like all you [ __ ]
political cuts out there bitching at me
you sound like all these [ __ ] fat
actresses out here who are bitching
about Hollywood acting as though they're
surprised that so much of this [ __ ]
industry is based on how you look what
was that really a shocker
had you never been to a movie you didn't
notice a trend do you think it's just
you you know what I mean
you [ __ ] sloppy tits who's having a
rough time I'm a [ __ ] bald redheaded
male I have no sympathy for you know
he's knocking down their [ __ ] door to
put me in an action movie you know I
could be Hellboy do a [ __ ] cycle of
steroids I already have the head you
just [ __ ] paint it red knee you're
ready to go I could do a headstand and
[ __ ] my head would turn so red you
could say it's the amount of money you'd
save on makeup and time alone bill do a
[ __ ] that handstand
okay you're in the scene anyways so I
guess the Obamas bought an eight point 1
million dollar house not an 82 million
dollar house which then led me into this
whole thing like he's on his this is his
third book that he's written it's like
he was writing books while he was
president aren't you supposed to be
running the [ __ ] country [ __ ] it's
sitting there dealing with the Russians
and all this terrorist groups and all
that [ __ ] and then you're like [ __ ]
at nighttime take a little legal pad it
was the best of times it was the worst
of times these [ __ ] [ __ ] aren't
right in the books they always got like
somebody else
it's like written by Bill Clinton and
the other guy who actually wrote the
book yeah I want to ride a thriller how
about you and me ride it right like
you'll put your name I'll put my name on
the cover and then you like ride it what
is that book about you got to write what
you know
it's got to be something about somebody
[ __ ] sneak around on his wife right
thinking cigars and people it's too
on-the-nose I wanted to be challenged I
wrote about a guy who was faithful um
sorry for the bad Bill Clinton now I
guess bill once you do your homework the
book Oxford in England the home where it
all started I take both of those games
I was working both days so I have to go
back and watch them and I got to tell
you Matt I am so [ __ ] sold on that
game now I don't know what happened I
had so much fun making fun of soccer all
these [ __ ] years and it's it's crazy
and then watching the highlights of when
a goal is scored like my whole my whole
complaint about the sport is what makes
the sports so great the fact that
scoring is so goddamn difficult the
[ __ ] that the emotion that gets let
off when these people score I mean Jesus
cry like in my country if you dumped a
beer on somebody after a some sort of
point is scored you're going to get into
a fight
over there I mean it'll go [ __ ] I
don't know what it look like he looked
like a sports bar combined with the
money shot in a porno everybody's
jumping up and down just spraying booze
all over the place part of me I think it
was a little annoying like what why you
wasted all that good booze you know cuz
I'm uh I'm taking another month off you
know me I impose my own little [ __ ]
sabbaticals you know what I mean and
after that that my little excursion over
there to Europe oh my god
it's just I I'll that says some cop
the 1664 that [ __ ] beer tastes so
goddamn good in that goddamn glass in
that one cafe over there in Europe over
there in France right that I refuse I've
seen it over here and I've been tempted
to buy it and it's like I'm not gonna
[ __ ] do it cuz this is what happens
like when you go to Ireland and you
drink Guinness over there and then you
come back here and you want to continue
it it [ __ ] sucks
and you know what else I did you know
what's just unbelievably like just on
another level is Indian food in England
I went to this [ __ ] place the Indian
food was so goddamn good I've been I
ordered it twice since then once in
France it was okay and then I ordered it
here in LA in it [ __ ] and I was like
I gotta walk away you know it's like you
go to Paris and you come home you like
you know I'm gonna have a French
breakfast I'm gonna get a saw right and
then you go down to the [ __ ]
supermarket and you get it and it's like
somebody pulled it out of their shoe you
know it just all goes back to the when
and rum thing yes go on you know I mean
that's the only thing that sucks about
travelling you know what I mean like I
think I'm gonna do a gig and Buffalo
coming up I've been there and [ __ ]
forever and what's gonna happen is I'm
gonna go to Duffy's or that other
[ __ ] place with you know where they
came up with buffalo wings and I'm gonna
eat them and they're gonna be so goddamn
good and then I'm gonna come back out
here I'm gonna have that [ __ ] crack in
my system going
I'm gonna get I gotta get some wings out
here and I'm gonna eat them and they're
gonna suck and then it's just depressing
you like the only place to get good
wings is in Buffalo
it really is I've never gone to any
other place other than Buffalo that
really knows how to make good buffalo
wings that's it
no I just lobbed that out there for all
of you guys to lose your [ __ ] [ __ ]
thank you much Buffalo I was jumpy I do
yeah good what you want to do is go to
Cincinnati and go to [ __ ] Muffy's
they have the best once I followed Joe
Rogan on all social media and he posted
this really fast than anything that
within 10 minutes I was like I don't you
know what the [ __ ] this guy's talking
about he was talking something about
fasting and how it's actually could be
good for ya right I mean Dick Gregory
wrote a whole bunch of books on this
type of [ __ ] right rest his soul and
saying how you know what's the organs
rejuvenate and all of that type of [ __ ]
and I thought it was really fascinating
until about 10 minutes in I realized I I
didn't understand what the guy was
talking about and I looked at him and he
was not in the best of shape he looked a
little mushy you know which I would
think would happen if you fasted you'd
get a little fleshy cuz your body would
keep eating muscle you know I mean I
don't know but anyways the [ __ ] was my
point I was talking about food oh Jesus
I don't [ __ ] know I have no idea
trouble in this suit it's the table over
like a [ __ ] baby
why am I talking about that because I
was watching TV late night and I watched
all these old eighties videos and that
song came on you know I'm telling you my
new show was 77 Sunset Strip with Efrem
Zimbalist jr. who I was always a big fan
of because that FBI show and and I've
been you know I've been maintained you
know I think yesterday was the first day
I snapped while driving in awhile and it
felt weird and I
immediately dialed it back down and my
move for all you other angry guys out
there like me and you're not angry
you're not an angry guy you just that's
your default emotion like you know what
I mean like to really be an angry guy
you just have to be like walking around
seething which I don't I walk around
totally normal and then something
happens and I [ __ ] flip out you know
and have a [ __ ] meltdown and then it
just takes people it's just it's so
[ __ ] over the top that everybody
forgets what a great guy was for the
previous four hours
that's essentially what it is and it's
like a [ __ ] five-minute meltdown you
know it's like what about the other four
hours where I was a good guy and it's
just like no bill no what you did in
that five minutes and he gated all that
it's like doing four hours of [ __ ]
cardio and then sitting down eating a
box of [ __ ] Oreo cookies it's just it
you just negated all of that it's over
you're still a fat [ __ ] emotionally so
anyways I listen to baseball I listen to
the Red Sox on Sirius XM and I actually
watch then I came home now it's making
me watch him again
[ __ ] Chris sales up goddamn beast he
watched the game last night when he
walked that guy he didn't think that he
walked him he got [ __ ] mad he started
throwing like 98 99 miles an hour on the
corners that crazy delivery I don't know
we shall see that I don't who that bum
was that they brought in the [ __ ]
eighth-inning then almost gate we were
up four to nothing and he's like you
know what let's make the gamblers
nervous
he's a nice fatty hanging out over the
plate BAM
base hit boom double four to one load
him up they finally got him out of there
then our relief pitcher I don't know
anybody's knee and that guy who comes
out there he hangs his arm like he's
drying a shirt or some [ __ ] he came out
there and shot him they'll [ __ ] down so
I'm like I'm back into that [ __ ] and I'm
actually gonna be really sad when the
World Cups over when is the finals out
on San that's gonna be crazy
one match for all the [ __ ] Marvel's
can you imagine if that comes down to
penalty kicks again I used to think that
was the stupidest [ __ ] thing ever
like a world fast like a basketball
championship coming down two foul shots
you know what I mean it would just be
like boring as [ __ ] but now I get it I
get it cuz if you [ __ ] it up I really
feel like the goaltender has like no
pressure cuz all he has to do is just
guess you know I love that they're
guessing it's just a total guess and
when they guess right they guess right
they stand up like like like there was
some sort of intelligent thought there
it's just like left-right left-right
diving left [ __ ] he went right that
always it's always funny when they guess
wrong when they're they start to dive
that way and they realized that guy went
the other way and you just watch the
goaltender like his whole body goes limp
like ah I should tell the other way and
he just [ __ ] lands on the grass but
the pressure on the shooter they don't
want to miss the net so I I'm gathering
it takes massive balls to try to shoot
it up top to go top corner which why
wouldn't you just go there he's not
gonna [ __ ] get that because it's like
what if I miss then I'm that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] missed for the rest of my
[ __ ] life and fat crooked great teeth
fish-and-chip eating [ __ ] [ __ ]
you can get my grill everywhere I go for
the rest of my life people who never
accomplished [ __ ] now can take out the
failure of their life on me because I
tried to go top shelf what do you guys
call it what do you what do you guys
call shelfs over there the bonnet the
boot what the [ __ ] do you always have
some stupid [ __ ] name for it I've
gotta said on cooking shows every
ingredient you guys pronounced
differently oregano oregano tomato
tomahto
basil Basel it's okay they just [ __ ]
with me there wasn't one thing did we
hate England that much by the end of it
I really think that we would like the
summer school kids that came over here
in like the weird religious people no we
all came over here and he had
people who weren't good in school
[ __ ] people that were too into
religion and those two people combined
made American sign and that's why I am
the product of that and I found an eight
point one million dollar house was
eighty two million dollars why don't you
go [ __ ] yourself
do my homework I'm not in [ __ ] school
alright I didn't getting this this
business to think all right let me let
me read it a little bit of advertising
here JFK blown away we're not doing it J
tipping over a [ __ ] table
I still love Billy Joel cuz he got so
hammered he drove his car through his
[ __ ] neighbors living room window I
mean can you can you loan him enough
sugar in your lifetime to get past that
you know every day I be knocking on door
hey man if you want to borrow a rake or
a wheelbarrow anything anything you know
bear oh by the way not barrel roll out
the bear oh we're raking some [ __ ]
leaves by the way Dean Delray from the
letter B talk podcast on all things
comedy has the legendary Henry Rollins
on his podcast this week this is a dream
guest for Dean Del Rey see if you want
to listen to him fanboy out while asking
all the questions you always wanted to
hear Henry Rollins answer give it take a
few check it out in the all things
coming up well let there be talk dean
del Rey with the great Henry Rollins who
had such a funny bit on Iron Maiden he
actually made me question whether I
think was I am [ __ ] for liking the band
and then of course I put on one of their
songs I was like now I wasn't I wasn't
right it sounds we read this book about
a bloke who had wings and flew too close
to the Sun so this song is about a bloke
who put some wings on and flew too close
to the Sun all right butcher box what
box delivers healthy 100% grass-fed and
grass-finished beef free-range organic
chicken and this is right this is the
money shot right here and heritage bread
pork it's the best goddamn pork chop
I've ever had in my life that I ever
made at my house I think maybe one time
I went to some five-star restaurant you
know the rep [ __ ] chefs walking
around wearing clogs you got to go to
one of those places you know there's all
these old bald guys like me with these
skinny young broads
you know aka their second or third wife
you know you got to go to a place like
that if you don't wanna drop that kind
of cash and you still want to the best
pork chop you ever gonna have you got to
get butcher bucks all right there
there's my personal fire that I just
made it personal okay the incredible
quality of butcher box meats
starts with the commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones before they kill them each
box comes with at least nine to 11
pounds of meat which is enough for 24
individual sized meals you could feed a
[ __ ] army you can choose from five
different box types all beef beef and
chicken beef and pork mix box go crazy
man throw as many animals in there as
you can custom box let you choose your
own cuts come on man it's the [ __ ]
get the grill going and get some butcher
box this ad always makes me hungry
that's how good the foodies been
antibiotics slash hormone free butcher
box believes in healthier food system
where everyone has access to meats the
way nature intended now like these cows
and mainstream where they got the fake
tits and the [ __ ] Botox
all right you want the original ones
free of antibiotics and hormones that
humanely raised on open pasture let them
walk around
selection is amazing butcher box
carefully curates the finest selection
and cuts and makes it a breeze to
customize your own delivery build your
own box to get exactly what you and your
family love choose your delivery
frequency with the customization it's
with customizable subscription recipes
are available on butcher boxes websites
and videos are available to follow along
a butcher bike you can't [ __ ] lose all
right to receive free bacon for life the
dream
goddamn meat eater out there plus $10
off your order go to butcher box comm
click on the big bacon banner on the
homepage and use BER at checkout go now
limited time offer all right for cig
Matic but this is stigmata Oh this
episode is brought to you by 4 Sigma
Tech 4 sig Matic the leading online
purveyors of shrooms man that's right
they're shelling shrooms on the Internet
but really this company sells mushroom
coffee that actually tastes great and is
damn good for you I [ __ ] love
mushrooms I would actually try this you
know I love mushroom soup I've always
wanted to try mushrooms you know I know
I know what you're gonna say talk to Ari
Shaffir for sig Matic is from Finland so
you know it's good the same country that
gave you Santa Claus angry beards and to
go ask you know it says the goaltender
for the Boston Bruins like you didn't
already know that and of course mushroom
coffee did you know that Finnish people
consume more coffee per capita than any
other country almost three times more
than Americans I don't like that we're
losing to them in coffee mushroom Coffee
has half the caffeine of regular coffee
but it's twice as magical it's easy on
the gut less acidic and you don't get
the jittery feeling you get from regular
coffee to it I'm sold
I'd love a nice hot cup of [ __ ]
mushroom coffee right now evidently I'm
drinking the mushroom coffee with lion's
mane and chaga lion's mane there's hair
in the [ __ ] coffee tastes just like
coffee not like mushrooms oh okay oh
they told me not to say it tastes like
mushrooms I guess it doesn't it tastes
like coffee lion's mane mushroom is your
brains best friend long used by Buddhist
monks they never lose their [ __ ] right
to help with focus during meditation I
gotta try this [ __ ] perfect for when I
need to get [ __ ] done
think of it as supercharged instant
coffee come I think on this is all in
the past tense like I've done this in my
life has changed for the better but I'm
sold
coming easy to use carry single-serving
packets perfect to take to work for
travel or when you're on the go get 15%
off your first purchase with code Burpee
you are are just go do for sig Matic
dot-com and try it out for yourself you
know Naz is gonna come out with his Co
his own coffee called for illmatic right
and see me made with I don't baby weed
and mushrooms I don't is the end of that
[ __ ] I have no idea me undies me undies
are made with a sustainably sourced
material oh wait a minute but Oh Popo me
undies me on B's the World Cup is coming
home dudududu biondi's biondi's it's
sick of [ __ ] being alone but then
England lost to the Croatians now that
cup is still on vacation and ain't
coming home any [ __ ] time soon sorry
to everybody over there congratulations
I love that number 2 number 10 on
Croatia that [ __ ] guy is a play
France has a great team I don't know who
to root for here
I obviously love France Patti oh I have
a great time when I'm over there
but I got to tell you man the Croatian
system good-looking goddamn people and
it's only 4.1 million of them according
to Pete Davidson there's more people in
New York City than is in their entire
country and they are in the finals so I
think I kind of have to root for them
cuz they're the underdogs again oh I'm
ruined for Croatia all right how does it
like I got to hear their national anthem
I got to learn that by Saturday Oh
[ __ ] Croatia there's only four million
cons Croatia
national national [ __ ] I almost wrote a
[ __ ] anthem and
you know this is gonna be some [ __ ]
Dracula Eastern European [ __ ] oh by the
way that tour is going down I'm getting
all the dates okay I'm not talking [ __ ]
I'm going out there
Croatian national anthem with English
lyrics
that's not very probation is it what do
they speak over there crow 80
all right let's it's only two and a half
minutes long I'm already liking this
it's like a Beatles song but where's the
[ __ ] where's the music
it's scrolling scrolling scrolling
[Music]
alright there's no [ __ ] way I'm gonna
be able to learn this right it comes
down it's very cinematic you know what I
like it I like it goddamn it it's very
cinematic I like cars two hours a big it
said it's based off a drinking song you
know we did we pulled a Jimmy Page when
we wrote it like out on the tiles I
guess Jason Bonham told that story on
that super group show on vh1 way back in
the day write that out on the tiles you
know but David Abbott buttered that OPEC
OPEC oh um that was actually a drinking
song I'm out on the Taos I had a little
drinking of some men of something and
I'm out on the Taos so Jimmy just you
know I guess Jon came in singing that
and Jimmy's like Ron what said song has
already been written me undies me undies
are made with sustainably sourced
material from Beach wood trees they're
naturally soft makes a fabric that won't
sag down or right up trust me once you
put on a pair you'll get it feel free to
improvise here about what you love about
me on these I love the way it cradles my
[ __ ] nuts the undies is so sure
you'll love your first pair if you're
not happy they'll do whatever they can
to get you into the right pair they'll
send a [ __ ] a horny another one and
if they can't keep them and they'll
refund you so it's really is risk free
try the best underwear ever and if
you're already part of the me undies fam
what up fam tell your friends about it
through their referral program they'll
get a discount and you'll get a store
credit
win-win it's like Amway meets [ __ ]
underwear still not sure well me undies
has a deal for my listeners first-time
purchasers get 15
percent off their first pair of me
undies and shipping is free that's 50%
off plus free shipping and a guarantee
that you and your me undies will be
happy together I can't see me wear it no
one DS bought these against my balls get
your butt over to me undies comm and
treat yourself me and you and you and me
to get your 15% off your first pair for
free shipping in 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies comm / /
that's my undies comm / burn and lastly
but not leastly helix comm well after
this I'm gonna tell you about my
stand-up set I had last night there's
nobody on the planet like you you're
special you have something to say and by
all means please a mote about it on
social media do you know I actually
tweeted about this on the Twitter there
they actually had a hashtag hashtag
things I don't tolerate oh my god it had
to be the most self-serving [ __ ]
thing ever it's just such an excuse for
everybody to see what a wonderful
open-minded person you are things they
don't tolerate bigotry mean people
people you tickling people who are
weaker you know isn't that all obvious
[ __ ] hashtag things that taste good ice
cream cookies helix there's nobody on
the planet like you so why don't [ __ ]
would you buy a generic mattress built
for everyone else maybe because you hate
shopping I don't know next please
mention all the talking points below
well I will if you write it I'll read it
HELOCs Leap matches your body to the
perfect mattress so you get the best
sleep of your life they developed nine
different mattresses tailored to
specific body types and sleep
preferences
alright so everybody's different but
there's only nine different designs
maybe there's all kinds of offshoots you
know I like everybody else
you're like one in nine people just go
to
hellix leap calm slash / take their two
minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
mattress that's perfect for you
contouring your body to provide
unprecedented comfort and better sleep
30% of helix sleep customers report
better sleep after switching to their
customized mattress from helic sleep
right now they're offering hey Neil
what's up come here the lovely need
everybody for up to one hundred twenty
five dollars off all mattress orders Nia
do you realize that you're a unique
human being yes your unique human being
you're only like one out of every nine
people one out of every nine well these
guys make unique mattress and I said
everybody's the same but they have nine
different mattress types
that's HELOCs okay to get 125 I don't
know they never told me he looks oh I
feel like I knew this and now I don't
remember
hey you finished reading this whether
you're a side sleeper hot sleeper like a
plush or farm bed they've got the
mattress that will fit just right get up
to 125 percent off at helix sleep calm
slash burn that's hella calm slash burn
for a hundred and twenty five dollars
off your mattress order helix sleep calm
slash / there you go it is it rhyme with
Felix
I think it's hellix I feel like I knew
this I feel like I gave you [ __ ] about
it now you don't remember eight so last
night I went last night I was out and
about I went to Bobcat Goldthwait's
has a new show on truTV called Bobcat
Goldthwait's was it monsters and misfits
and monsters something like that I don't
know what it is but it's on truTV I
watched an episode of it last night it's
[ __ ] it's classic Bobcat it's totally
original if you just look up if you just
search Bobcat Goldthwait right if you do
that you're gonna find it's on truTV
well it was last night what was last
night Wednesday Wednesday so Wednesday
night at 10 o'clock on truTV
go so I went down to the premiere I got
there late because I was working as an
actor I had to take off my little
[ __ ] tights when I was done acting
and I was feeling guilty because I
wanted to go down there I had friends I
had to see them but I hadn't done
stand-up in a minute and I'm gonna be in
Portland in Seattle this weekend so I
got to shake the [ __ ] rust off
Portland and Seattle with you
well yeah it's only a southwest or
Alaskan flight away yeah I want to go I
don't have a friend in Portland I've
always wanted to see Portland and I just
feel like the microphone is so close oh
sorry
yeah and I've never been to Seattle
either both places I don't wanna go I
invited you yeah you did
can I get back to my story so this is
what I love about LA so I'm walking out
I Aubert over right smoked a cigar with
one of my great friends in this business
and then I was walking out going at me
and I didn't do stand-up should I pause
I don't want a [ __ ] uber over there
and then we'll go home [ __ ] this so I
just start walking home and I walked by
a [ __ ] and there was these young
comics barking out front a comedy show
coming they saw me coming down the
street and they laugh a you want to go
to calm me show I said no and they go
you want to go up I'm like nah thank you
though and then I walked about 10 feet
it's like [ __ ] I need to get a set it
and I went in there and I did a set at
Hooters last night upstairs in the big
room the main room it was a bunch of
young kids there no what about the
Buffalo shrimp yeah I literally walked
in it was awesome they put me on like
the [ __ ] president they put me on
immediately I went up of course bill
everybody knows you at Hooters I I went
on and I said I'd do 10 to 15 I feel
like I did around 12 it felt like a 12 I
got my laps I shook the rust off and I
[ __ ] walked out it was great it was
perfect then I walked out walked halfway
down the block and there was a taxi
which I love old school and I got into
it I say I say you work any guys he goes
yeas and I got in I got your doing he
goes yeah so so I was like all right I
appreciate that
and he goes
and he left this [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] [ __ ] Drive it home just curse
good I can be myself just cursing
everybody in the way a great night
yes without alcohol I don't need it man
can we just talk about Hooters for a
second I really love the the Buffalo
shrimp what is it
yeah it's shrimp with buffalo sauce it's
just like oh and they give you like this
blue cheese dipping sauce to go with it
oh my god do blue cheese is the most
disgusting one of one of the more
disgusting foods you know that we watch
an Undercover Brother and they were
talking about how white people like
white people like me very underrated
movie by the way yeah white people like
mayonnaise and evidently black people
don't I don't [ __ ] know
my whatever I don't know what I like
mayonnaise I like mayonnaise on fries I
like mayonnaise on roast beef I like
mayonnaise in front of people that don't
enjoy mayonnaise no I like but blue
cheese is just oh god it's like Buffalo
shrimp and and blue cheese oh my god
it's just like it's like a it's like
mucus it's gross
well I think when you eat wings you just
eat the wings you don't even use any of
the sauce no ran what about ranch what
are your feelings about ranch it's it's
all right no I know I like ketchup
I like the ketchup mayonnaise mustard
like basic yeah I'm a basic white dude I
like pickles yep
look I like I stay here's a nice
surprise here you can see that I've
traveled I like a stuffed olive does
that make me interesting am i walking it
out do some dance from years ago
oh god I'm an Instagram I know all the
latest dances I really need
get up do the mashed potato for me I
gotta get you to do a in my feelings
challenge alright go ahead do it well
the dance you gotta play the song to
dance it's a dance that you do to a
Drake song called in my feelings I can't
stand Drake do you love me
are you riding you haven't seen I can't
stand that guy not literally that guy
you used to you used oh he's always
whining about somebody it's just like
he's got this great life he's banging
models and I gotta sit there listening
to him whining about the model that he
used to [ __ ] who doesn't call him back
anymore
it's like Drake you were just [ __ ]
her she moved on he isn't he's selfish
but he loves magic I've seen like three
different videos of him running away
after a trick that's what's really funny
about black people is you can you can
see somebody hustling you lying to you
and all that type of [ __ ] you know you
just just you can smell [ __ ] from a
mile a [ __ ] way but you get a
magician does a card trick you guys run
away like he's a witch it's that it's
slight a hint near if that guy could do
that [ __ ] if that guy could do that [ __ ]
he would just [ __ ] like levitate into
a bank vault he wouldn't be [ __ ]
hustle and doing magic on a street
corner right with the magic [ __ ] all
right
playing with evil forces with the magic
[ __ ] you heard that that should be on a
t-shirt playing with the evil forces
with the magic [ __ ] that has to be in a
rap song has to be in something I don't
like hate Drake I just like his [ __ ]
music is just like you know you know
like those guys that just call up and
they just dump your day that day on you
like do ever any good mood what happened
now Drake expose you know his family
life that he was trying to keep private
you know
yeah that's none of my business I
thought I thought that was weak that was
weak doing that [ __ ]
we didn't start the fire all right I
gotta get I gotta get off my dick oh my
god I hate that's Charlie Chaplin Teddy
Roosevelt [ __ ] people from the past
bobba bobba bobba do bill stop [ __ ]
avoiding the topic saying a generation
did a lot of shitty things troubling
it's the worst line ever all right
having said that I loved I liked a lot
of his songs I feel like you're now
gonna talk about what you don't like
about me in the relationship yep so I
feel like you don't talk about things
that you like you always talk about what
you don't like just what's going on and
on how I love soccer and I hated soccer
and I loved it but there's been this
whole [ __ ] transformation yeah
because you focus on the negative no
he's such an [ __ ] we finally became
friends again we're buddies again
because of the work that I put in excuse
me what about me
Nonie I told you you becoming like this
goth chick that Shops at Hot Topic that
was your vibe gloom and doom modern
references
do they not exist anymore I don't know
do they I don't know
[ __ ] you haven't last time I talked to
you where are you I'm at the Grove
oh yeah but they don't have a hot topic
so mm-hmm do they still exist I don't
know they are high-end
all right go ahead [ __ ] on me what do
you got no no you're right we're friends
again after having a little moment there
so
positive I think you're great I think
with the devil ship with the creepy
vibes or whatever the [ __ ] he said
anyways I was trying to end on an upbeat
note who wore it better the Marvin Gaye
beard Drake or Marvin Gaye Rock the
Marvin Gaye beer better than wood who
Ward that red hat better Marvin Gaye or
Jacques Cousteau and now my goal is to
try to get you not to say Marvin Gaye
who was more important and I can't go
that route you'll get upset with that
one I didn't even have anything there
why'd you have to keep saying Marvin
Gaye it's an improv thing should have
gone to Jacques Cousteau then I had gone
the French way I had the ocean out lady
just painted me into a corner
yeah I killed upstairs in the big room
and didn't even bother to give Buffalo
shrimp it's like yeah I was too busy
killing upstairs arrow hooter Hooters in
the big room well I guess they're moot
they're moving their show across the
street looters I don't [ __ ] know
whatever's across the street did [ __ ]
Hollywood Boulevard you know we didn't
have a we didn't have any fire for the
cigars there so we had to go to into
tourist play having fire so we robbed
some mad she's [ __ ] together and went
into one of those touristy places and I
bought a I love California lighter for
my buddy who hates LA which is yeah it
was like three bucks and then it ran out
of lighter fluid
five dollars it's like no you need to be
selling these souvenirs for 50 cents if
that my favorite thing is when you go to
New York and they had that you know let
that foam
rubber thing where you wear the crown
from the [ __ ] Statue of Liberty
people walk around with that like I went
to New York and I got this can you
imagine how many of those are floating
around the [ __ ] ocean some poor
[ __ ] porpoise is trying to swallow
that thing all right well I'm out of
time yeah cuz I got I got [ __ ] to do
here or is it 52 minutes thank you for
coming on here in bringing the
positivity you take great but double
[ __ ] with the evil stuff over there
whatever the [ __ ] you say
alright that's the podcast thank you
everybody for listening you know my
apologies to anybody out there who is
offended I don't apologize
alright that's something that I'm mature
adult does please enjoy the music and
ill half-hour of a greatest hits from a
Thursday afternoon podcast just before
Friday Monday morning podcast whatever
the [ __ ] I say and I have a great couple
of days you cleansing or checking in
Thursday the final session
[Music]
can you be on the gorillas into home and
I imagine in people
as much as we are
[Music]
when summers a Kalos
some of us live in houses
some of its like to the loose footing
[Music]
you guys see that I just saw a
commercial for Kentucky Fried Chicken
where the parents are all excited
because the two bratty kids won't sit
still at the dinner table but they got
him this [ __ ] chicken and they're
feeding it to him they're basically very
subtly saying that there's drugs in this
chicken that will make you [ __ ]
children chill the [ __ ] out
[ __ ] I mean like you know not not the
way they mean it over there
in Great Britain you can't say that on
the comedy so you can say it in a comedy
club over in Scotland but you'll have a
rough LLL have a rough go of it if you
say the kid was [ __ ] over there that
means like severely mentally challenged
over here it just means you're not gonna
get laid to you 26 when you're in grad
school looking over a [ __ ] cadaver
right with some other [ __ ] nerd nerd
right and you're just sitting there
going you know the ankle bones connected
to the knee bone right has any of this
made any sense what shouldn't it's
[ __ ] Sunday night and I am spent
and I got a whole bunch of [ __ ] I have
to do tomorrow so I got to do it tonight
alright I'm off my game all right you
you cleanse your liver in like 40 to 43
days or something like that every drunk
I knows has told me that every drunk I
know that does not have a medical degree
has told me that if you go forty to
forty three days you will cleanse your
liver at least to the booze you know now
if you [ __ ] you start doing blow or
you know eating a bunch of trans fat
[ __ ] food or feeding your kids
Kentucky Fried [ __ ] chicken Jesus
Christ what happened to parents but you
got a drug your kids to keep him under
control you know you know what if kids
don't respect their parents they respect
him but they don't respect like oh my
god this this person could wring my neck
could pick me up by my hair right could
grab a paddle and [ __ ] you know
mostly hit my ass but also kind of hit
my lower back because I'm squirming
right that doesn't exist anymore so now
these kids are so [ __ ] out of control
these people have to go down a Kentucky
Fried Chicken okay and I used the term
chicken very loosely to go down and
whatever that is that's in that bucket
okay it doesn't have a beak but doesn't
have feet if it's [ __ ] you know chest
is breast is sticking out like the cast
on [ __ ] what was what was that show
with the Italians they're on New Jersey
Shore Jersey Shore right my world that's
not a [ __ ] chicken you know you want
the chicken that looked like Mark
McGwire and his rookie season you don't
want to eat the chicken that looks like
Mark McGwire when he [ __ ] played for
the Cardinals you know do you eat a
regular [ __ ] chicken first of all
it's gonna look like a pigeon to you
because you're so used to seeing those
roided-up once that they have murderers
row that you got down there it's your
[ __ ] Shahs right your Vaughn's your JC
Penney's wherever the [ __ ] you buy your
goddamn chicken you go down you go down
to any one of the mainstream [ __ ]
supermarkets okay and I swear to go when
you get to the chicken section okay if
you if you slept for the last 30 years
like that Van Gundy guy under the bridge
whatever his [ __ ] name is Van
Morrison the hell's his name Rip Van
Winkle right it was one of those people
one of the vans if you slept for the
last 30 years and you went down okay and
they showed you what a chicken was you'd
be like you'd be like that ain't no
chicken okay that's a goddamn Turkey I
know a [ __ ] time no can't be done no
sir no sir
get off my property okay I'm done with
your witchcraft okay yeah take it the
[ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] off my property
I wanna get the gun yeah you would think
it was a [ __ ] turkey and the thing is
is now it's a chicken and I remember I
watch one of those food inks one of
those [ __ ] liberal goddamn thinks you
know talking about flying carpets and
electric roads and all that [ __ ]
somewhere in there they were talking
about you know the food supply and how
poison it is poisonous poisoning than it
is is so I [ __ ] went down to a
farmer's [ __ ] market and I said I
wanna I wanna I wanna
all I want I wanna I want an all-natural
[ __ ] chicken I can't even talk I'm so
tired
one an all-natural chicken the guy goes
these are all-natural and I said
all-natural and he goes well I'm like
come on where is it and he had to walk
around the corner I'm sitting over there
lonely I swear to God looking like a
dove look-alike and somebody killed the
[ __ ] dump because right there that
one right there
is 100% all-natural nothing's wrong with
it and I was like I was like what at
what that's what a chicken's supposed to
look like and he raised his eyebrows and
he kind of put his lips together so they
were a straight line and then he nodded
you know that looked that people do like
like yeah I'm in the matrix I realized
I'm in the matrix but you know I knocked
the [ __ ] up so I gotta be selling these
roided-up chickens no anyways any what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about so basically
that's what these people are eating over
there okay there they are drugging up
their kids but I can't get mad at them
because I actually did that to Charlie
Murphy and donnell rawlings I've told
this story before hey I'll tell it
against my [ __ ] podcast I actually
drug the exact thing that they're doing
in that Kentucky Fried Chicken
commercial where they're trying to get
their kids to sit still
by just feeding him so full of these
[ __ ] trans fats from these roided-up
be closed [ __ ] chickens with their
dolly parton breasteses right
I did that to [ __ ] Donnell and
Charlie I was hungover and we were
taking a car service from Chicago as a
knees up to one of those whatever the
[ __ ] it was Saint Charles it was a three
city run and one of them was Saint
Charles so we're getting in the [ __ ]
limo Don ELLs in rare form
Charlie's in rare form they're [ __ ]
gabbing and thrashing people and me and
everybody and I just don't want to hear
it I'm like I don't want to listen to
these [ __ ] guys running that goddamn
yaps in the back of this car the whole
[ __ ] way up I want a nice quiet ride
this is gonna suck and I walked outside
hungover
and I walked into the Chicago where you
know I almost got hit by three fat
people and I looked up the street and I
saw it I saw Popeyes and I was like oh
thank god
and I [ __ ] walked in there and I got
all this [ __ ] popeyes chicken with
biscuits and all of this [ __ ] food and I
brought it back to the car and as the
car pulled up they came out and I say
guys I got herself some [ __ ] out of some
food and they la that's [ __ ] great you
know they were hungry or whatever and
they started showering that [ __ ]
Popeyes food and I sat back nibbling on
a drumstick and I swear to God
ten minutes later they were asleep I'm
not lying they were [ __ ] asleep
snoring the whole way up and I was just
sitting there loving life the whole
[ __ ] ride up and I you know what I
admitted to him later they thought it
was funny but that's basically what it
is they called it the itis that's what
they call it when you eat that [ __ ] food
and then you have to go to sleep they
call it the itis I guess and by they I
mean African Americans they call it the
[ __ ] itis and that's what they got
they learned that from Donnell because I
don't know how that man stayed in shape
but he had the worst diet he's one of
those guys who like you stop for gas and
he comes out of the gas station with
like one of those
gas station hot dogs and he would eat it
and then he would immediately fall
asleep and I got I would say that
Charlie look at this guy he's sleeping
and chive but yeah man he got the itis
and he explained that to me and with
that little bit of information it went
into my evil white brain and I drug my
two african-american friends way back in
the year 2005 and that's a little
chicken story for you once how'd you
like that everybody so that's what the
[ __ ] they're saying right there that's
what Kentucky Fried Chicken is allegedly
saying I guess I have to say alleged so
they're lawyers on retainer don't attack
my [ __ ] podcast as far as I can tell
I'm asking you right now Kentucky Fried
Chicken hiding behind your [ __ ]
letters KFC is that what the [ __ ] you do
is that what you saying if you got kids
who are not stimulated enough that they
can't even sit down if you haven't a
Reata running around you gotta tie your
kids out open the door you send them out
in the [ __ ] yard go outside get
outside and play that's what you do like
a goddamn one of those [ __ ] Irish
dogs that was bred tiptoe to herd sheep
you gotta let that [ __ ] thing run
around run around in circles go get out
there take a ball you just [ __ ] throw
it out in traffic and let the dog run
around dodging cars it comes in its
gonna lay down okay it's not gonna jump
all over company sticking its cold nose
right in there [ __ ] hoo hush that's
what you got to do with your kid you got
to send him outside right but to catch a
predator and all these other [ __ ]
shows you know all these shows on TV
where people forget their kids are in a
car with the windows rolled up and that
kids are too [ __ ] dumb to roll them
down or they're too weak because they
haven't gone outside and climbed a
[ __ ] tree and they stay in there and
then their brains get cooked like a
boxer you know you know that dog boxers
they know they don't do well on the Sun
well neither do fat kids if you leave
the windows rolled up you know and they
got those weak arms at all they don't
think the most tedious things they ever
did was
a rapper off of a [ __ ] and ice-cream
sandwich right you can't leave them in
the car my mother left us in the car all
the [ __ ] time she would go to school
she was going to school during the day
trying to further her education and she
left five [ __ ] kids in the car with
the windows rolled up in money for
Burger King and she would say to us just
go into the burg that's the only time
you were to leave this car over the left
over the next three [ __ ] up when I'm
in class and she would disappear around
the corner after we said absolutely mom
and she walked away and we immediately
would get out of the car start walking
up and down the streets in Boston we
going to [ __ ] Burger King and we'd
have some to eat do you know what would
happen nowadays if they just saw five
[ __ ] dirty face kids walking up and
down calm F Boylston Street going into a
Burger King looking like the cast of
[ __ ] Annie someone would have filmed
it and my mother would have been they
would have taken us away you know but
but they didn't because there was no
cameras back then or videotape ones I
mean there was but only people Adam
alike the news and a young Steven
Spielberg so we went in there we [ __ ]
got some food climbed on cars and
[ __ ] yelled at people and [ __ ] you
know hang it on Park parking meters and
all that hence we had the [ __ ]
forearm strength to roll down the
windows and none of us ever had an issue
in the car and you know what I think
that's one to grow on
so there you go people I'm not saying
KFC is food I'm not just kidding I'm not
saying it's bad food every once in a
while who's kidding home every once we
great if he could just [ __ ] do
heroine the way you can eat McDonald's
just like every once in a while he'd
just be like you know what yeah let's
just [ __ ] tie off not off for the
rest of the [ __ ] day in like the
people at work understood it you know
hey where were you yesterday I got this
black tar heroin came in you know hadn't
done it like three months away figured
[ __ ] it
oh is that what you did how was it how
was it you know look you went to a room
he said I thought it was awesome I don't
have a [ __ ]
she can't you know he'd get addicted to
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast for
Monday July 12 2010 hola I'm sorry I was
really gonna act like I could speak
Spanish there hola yo soy Kumiko anemia
village a Huna man sauna
pantalones una camisa I actually if you
can't tell
I've actually finally broken open my
rosetta stone that I got for Christmas
two and a half [ __ ] years ago
whatever it is yeah I got it for a year
and a half ago December of 2008 I got
the rosetta stone
Oh God Oh Blanco Negro Rojo I uh I got
it dude it's a [ __ ] it's the [ __ ] I'm
gonna be fluent in Spanish I've always
wanted to learn another language and I
am trying to immerse myself that's what
I'm trying to do I'm trying to immerse
myself in the language I'm listening to
it on the radio I'm also listening to it
uh you know I'm listening to [ __ ] like
this on on my itunes hoping I can pick
up some [ __ ] you know you got it you got
a murse yourself in this [ __ ] you gotta
listen stop like this
[Music]
a [ __ ] great is that God to have a
[ __ ] and be able to [ __ ] know what
that means
sing that have pigment in my chest so I
can actually wear that open I'm gonna go
stab a bull Latino shirt how much [ __ ]
would you get if he could [ __ ] it's
just unbelievable just half the [ __ ]
that they say it sounds like [ __ ]
dirty talk when you're banging a girl
he'll need you baby lychee that means a
girl is drinking them he's drinking milk
there's no way to say that without just
sounded like your [ __ ] little Nene a
baby lychee hey next time you guys are
banging a girl okay you got a doggy
style just lean down in her ear she'll
either have an orgasm or a [ __ ] whirl
around an elbow when you in the face
either way either way it's gonna be
funny but I'm gonna be fluent in that
[ __ ] and I'm liking rosetta stone I
really like it you sit there and you put
on like a Bill Bellamy Janet Jackson
sort of headset you know and you put on
some stretchy pants and then you put
your put in the [ __ ] cd-rom or
whatever the hell it is and then they
just they just start speaking to you
like you're a baby sitting in the crib
that's exactly what it is
- very stereotypical Mexican looking
faces just sort of peer into the screen
like you're laying in the crib and then
they just start speaking to you and they
tickle your tummy it's it's tremendous
it's a tremendous it's a tremendous way
to nam I'm just [ __ ] around through
it it's awesome
it's if you ever thinking about doing it
like you know I always wanted to learn
to speak a different language
whenever I rode this subway I was
nervous that Puerto Ricans were actually
calling me bad words what does puto mean
is that even Porto Rican this is what's
killing me this is how [ __ ] what I am
I actually believe that I'm gonna
learn this [ __ ] el Nene ability I'm
gonna learn this [ __ ] and therefore I
will be able to go to Mexico Cuba Puerto
Rico Brazil or whatever and be able to
understand every [ __ ] out there
even though people I know this dude
who's Cuban and he tells me it's it's
really different not totally different
but I mean I don't know he seemed a
little peeved when I was like yeah and I
can go to [ __ ] Cuba I can go to
Dominican Republic it's not the [ __ ]
same thing alright sorry you know well
it's one of those things I'm not even
trying to be offensive and I offended
you but it's like you know do you think
when I go to Ireland or I went to went
to Scotland I could understand those
[ __ ] everything that they said but I
knew what they were saying
am I being ignorant right here do you
guys is it a company it's not a
completely different language
huh he'll mean your baby leche you can't
say that [ __ ] Cuba and they won't
know what just you're talking about is
that because economy communism
you know I already stopped this podcast
and started it again because I'm doing
this Sunday morning my [ __ ] brain
isn't awake yet stuttering like a
goddamn jackass pantalones Sabattus una
camisa i can't [ __ ] wait I can't wait
the first time somebody from I was gonna
say somebody from another language
that's how dumb I am somebody speak in
Spanish talk [ __ ] about me because I'll
tell you right now I would [ __ ] do it
all the time
I would do it all the goddamn time if
English was the second language was not
the main language of this country and I
had another english-speaking friend I
and I was walking around people who did
not understand English and it would be
our own little private language I would
be [ __ ] on people right and left
perverted stuff can you imagine that if
nobody understood English everybody just
spoke Spanish right your boss is some
[ __ ] but she's got a nice rack and
you're sitting in she can literally walk
by and like dude I would tit [ __ ] this
[ __ ] write on a goddamn desk and then
turn around me hola me basta
you know
no wonder this so [ __ ] laid-back they
can get it out
I got a sit I got a sit on all this
goddamn rage because I don't have some
secret [ __ ] language alright alright
Mexicans I'm in you [ __ ] hideout and
I'm breaking down your code so I'm
telling you this time next year you
better watch your tongue okay good only
I could turn learning another language
si si si you hear me stuttering it's in
the morning only I could turn speaking
another language mi only I could turn
you love a language relax Mexico just
relax just really listen to a couple of
my podcasts and realize how [ __ ]
stupid I am
and also how I get totally psycho into
something for about 10 days and then I
just walk away from it and then it just
sits there gathering dust on my desk
anyways so it was a big week this week
in in sports it's actually what time is
it right now it's ten forty three and
this is the funny thing in 17 minutes
the World Cup final is starting which is
basically the championship one of the
true championships of the world it's the
entire world competes for it and as big
a [ __ ] sports fan as I am I could
give a [ __ ] the only thing that I would
find less interesting than the World Cup
final was the LeBron James hour-long
press conference to announce what team
he's gonna [ __ ] go to you know that's
actually [ __ ] I totally respect the
game of soccer
it just it [ __ ] bores the [ __ ] out of
me and we have a number of soccer fans
on here and they send me emails and they
get mad at me
they say says dear bill dude until you
have a better understanding of the game
you got to stop ragging on soccer find
someone that knows a little bit about
the game and takes some [ __ ] time and
watch a couple of games dude watch the
World Cup Finals exclamation point
what cuz you [ __ ] say so do you
realize that if you added up everyone
that watched the NFL the NBA the NHL
be you would only have about half as
many people that watch soccer do do you
realize that I'm not so [ __ ] stupid
that I don't realize that you just
pulled that stat out of your ass
give me some numbers you didn't you said
you would have about half isn't about
really yeah you're gonna guesstimate
there put that in your pipe and smoke it
bill thanks dude
all right this is the deal all right I'm
so sick of these [ __ ] soccer [ __ ]
trying to convince me that it's an
exciting sport do you think that I
haven't sat down and watched it
earlier this year when I watched the
Olympics I got into curling I was
watching the cross-country skiing will
you shoot the gun I'm very open-minded
when it comes to sports ok but to sit
there and kill two three [ __ ] hours
of my day to watch a zero to zero
[ __ ] game and watching these guys
flop around like a bunch of goddamn Pau
Gasol's every 10 [ __ ] minutes it's
it's I tried dude I tried and just
because the whole [ __ ] world is
watching this sport does it mean that I
should alright
the whole world was wearing acid-washed
jeans and the late [ __ ] 80s I
followed that trend and I got the
embarrassing goddamn pictures to prove
it what if [ __ ] did that get me you know
what I like about soccer
I like the highlights the highlights you
know and they show in slow motion motion
absolutely gorgeous sport to watch but
to sit there for [ __ ] two hours
listen to those goddamn mosquito horns
you're really asking too much
all right everybody flopping around like
a bunch of goddamn [ __ ] girls get off
the goddamn ground [ __ ] [ __ ] the
guy doesn't even touch you and you flop
around on the ground it's so effeminate
that's what I can't stand about that
sport you know this guy did bring up a
good point because you're telling me the
basketball players yes basketball
players do basketball is a very [ __ ]
effeminate sport when it comes to that
[ __ ]
that fake [ __ ] flopping around you
know no other you know that's the
closest thing I'm trying to think
there's a couple guys in the NHL look
there's always gonna be a couple of
broads in every sport you know but at
least in in in the NHL soccer fan you
know what they have they have a penalty
for pretending that somebody hit you two
minutes you get it's called diving two
minutes for diving get up your [ __ ] and
get in the goddamn penalty box I was
high dude I tried I [ __ ] tried I
tried to watch the [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] I find the Premier League way more
enjoyable to watch I can watch that game
but I got to tell you like I don't know
what it is I start to get a headache and
I get a little bit of a stomachache when
I'm watching it because the amount of
effort that I have to put in to you know
dude to sit there in in in two hours of
your [ __ ] life to watch a 1 to
nothing game
that's why you know son I think I
finally figured out why they fight in
NHL hockey cuz you can actually have a
one to nothing [ __ ] game so you know
then you basically have guys going it's
legal to smash somebody you know against
the boards you can drop the gloves he
could fight there's a lot of other
exciting things that do happen all right
but to sit there for two [ __ ] hours
oh my god oh my god I got ahh yeah yeah
yeah it's the sports equivalent to
[ __ ] blue balls I don't [ __ ] like
it I really don't I I just don't I don't
like it I don't [ __ ] like it okay and
you can't make me [ __ ] like it
because the whole world likes it
alright there's this is a major part of
the [ __ ] world dad you know they take
out a high-grade piece of sandpaper and
then they they rub the girls [ __ ]
clicks off that doesn't mean that I
think it's right wow that was really
disgusting I'm sorry I'm sorry twelve
minutes into the podcast getting that
[ __ ] gross I should have saved that
towards the end for the die-hard fans um
so anyways dad that LeBron James
announcement speaking of mind-numbing
League boring oh let's not think about
[ __ ] soccer like I'm invited to this
distance
party where they're gonna watch the
finals and whatever you find a person
who's really into soccer you know yeah
they always got like the dead little
soccer shirt on they they always have
like these little [ __ ] wimpy torsos
if you notice that was the last time you
saw somebody jacked that was in the
[ __ ] soccer you don't always have
like those little [ __ ] those little
European torsos you know your little
seventh-grade bodies does anybody lift
weights or do push-ups or anything and
[ __ ] Europe do you just you just take
the torso God gave you and then you just
start stuffing fish and chips down your
[ __ ] throat and you just let it all
sort of slide down until you look like
Jethro Tull all right I think I've
trashed that [ __ ] enough let's trash an
American sports let's talk about [ __ ]
LeBron James and his [ __ ] first of
all his Howdy Doody puppets shirt that
he wore you know there really is this
theory out there that black guys are so
cool that they really can wear any type
of clothing and make it look good well
that was an example when it doesn't
quite always work I mean that was I
don't know what that was that looked
like he was gonna go sing on the Grand
Ole Opry in like 1948
all right the [ __ ] am I talking about
let's get into this whole podcast thing
all right the LeBron James one-hour
announcement for everybody out there
who's saying how [ __ ] lame it was you
know whose fault that is it's your own
goddamn fault it's your own [ __ ]
fault for sitting there and watching it
okay it's not like ESPN lied they told
you what it was gonna be this is gonna
be a one-hour special of an athlete
announcing which team he's gonna go
[ __ ] play for I mean how long should
that realistically take it's like the
[ __ ] Oscars how long should it take
to be and to take to just [ __ ] be
like and the Oscar goes to Sean Connery
and the Oscar for the best [ __ ] dress
in a period piece goes to Claire bill
Billingsley bill Billingsley Claire bill
Billingsley
[ __ ] douchebag Gober not even [ __ ]
awake trying to do a podcast to get it
out of the goddamn way to go to some
stupid ass [ __ ] party that's showing
the finals of a sport that he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about that starts in nine
minutes oh my god somebody hit [ __ ]
record um yeah I mean you know what the
[ __ ] it was gonna be why did you even
watch it I mean can't you tell that that
guy that guy just got some [ __ ]
horrific and he just got horrific advice
from his people around him who they were
just like we are gonna create the
biggest media stir ever all right we'll
go to Chicago first will gain some
interest we'll go to the Knicks we'll
get some interest and we'll go down a
[ __ ] man ooh where the [ __ ] is he
gonna who gives a [ __ ]
nobody cares except the people in those
[ __ ] towns I got to tell you I really
did enjoy him [ __ ] you know tearing
the hearts out of Knicks fans because as
always New York fans are the most [ __ ]
just like that's the sense of
entitlement that fans of New York sports
have just because they live in New York
City if I have to watch one more [ __ ]
[ __ ] on TV talk about the big stage
in New York okay
overrated underrated for this week
overrated the big stage in New York
there's only one big stage in New York
it's in [ __ ] Yankee Stadium that's
the only big stage that is in New York
27 championships you go there there is
pressure to win what is this big like
when LeBron didn't pick [ __ ] on New
York I'm on you know I'm online and I
read three comments and I'm like there
you go that's enough evidence for me I'm
gonna judge every new fan in New York
right now they were all sitting there
going like oh he was afraid of the
bright lights he couldn't handle the big
stage of New York let me ask you this
Knick fans where is the big [ __ ]
stage for professional basketball in New
York City
huh Madison Square Garden that place the
biggest thing that happens in Madison
Square Garden every year is Elton John
comes there and South he [ __ ] sells
out 20 shows you know Bruce Springsteen
comes there and sings his songs about
New Jersey this circus comes once a
[ __ ] year those are the biggest days
every year in Madison Square Garden
alright and in case you don't know what
I'm talking about next time you go there
and there's yet another horrific played
by made by either the [ __ ] Rangers of
the Knicks and you look up and disgust
to that to the sports gods like what the
[ __ ] when you're done praying for some
Messiah to come in there and save those
two pathetic [ __ ] franchises look up
at the ceiling and tell me what you see
a striking lack of championship [ __ ]
banners I'll even give me the goddamn
answers you dumb [ __ ] there is no big
stage and it's so [ __ ] disrespectful
of everybody to say that all the [ __ ]
time talking about me you know when they
talk about the biggest stage in in major
major league baseball that what do they
say Fenway Park how about st. Louis say
they got they got ten [ __ ] World
Series titles that's not even a good
example it's not like the Knicks are in
second place with titles dude Yankee
Stadium is the big stage and made Major
League Baseball ok the [ __ ] Celtics
have 17 NBA championships that we're all
one in Boston
alright the Los Angeles Lakers 11 titles
have been won there a once-a-year they
hold hands with somebody from Minnesota
and they add the five that were that's
that's the thing right there the
Minneapolis Lakers have more titles than
the [ __ ] in New York Knicks do you guys
understand that that a team that's that
that [ __ ] moved West
alright that moved [ __ ] West around
the same time the Brooklyn Dodgers went
out to LA still has three more [ __ ]
titles than you do you don't have a big
stage there and nobody is afraid to play
in New York City and they're certainly
not afraid to play the [ __ ] Knicks so
get off your own dicks I'm sick of it
alright the Jets haven't won it since 69
the Knicks haven't won it since 73 the
Mets haven't worn it since [ __ ] 86
who else has left the Giants are a
respectable franchise that's the best
you have you have a respectable
franchise that is one the same amount of
Super Bowls as the Patriots the Packers
the Redskins and the Raiders
the Giants are in the middle of the pack
all right there's no big [ __ ] stage
and they sit there and they act like
these sports writers in New York these
fat Mantid jackasses these film us
Knicks are gonna intimidate a guy at the
level of [ __ ] LeBron James they're
not I hate to tell it to you in New York
the reason why he didn't go to Madison
Square Garden is cuz you suck
that's why
think about that who the [ __ ] wouldn't
want to go play in New York you know New
York is the city is the Paris of [ __ ]
of America it's the best [ __ ] city we
have all right but just because there's
a bunch of people outside of Madison
Square Garden succeeding and doing some
[ __ ] most of whom aren't even from New
York by the way
that's another thing New Yorkers think
they're the [ __ ] just because they live
there just cuz they're standing on the
corner of [ __ ] 52nd 3rd eating a
slice you know if I can make it there
I'll make ed Eddie where are you really
making it with your dirty [ __ ]
sneakers standing there outside of Tad's
steaks you're not doing [ __ ] none of you
are all you [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
[ __ ] gathering outside of [ __ ]
Port Authority that's another thing of
oh man I'm trashing New York this week I
don't give a [ __ ] listen me I don't give
a [ __ ] who bill really are you being
dangerous it's dangerous to make a lone
Bray and a dangerous all um dude Frank
Sinatra's from New Jersey okay he was
bridge-and-tunnel the kind of the kind
of guy that Paris Hilton wouldn't have
[ __ ] in one of her [ __ ] nightclubs
down there in the Meatpacking District
if he came in and said oh I live in
Hoboken she would have turned a little
pointy nose up to the ceiling and walked
away in a big [ __ ] sasquatch feet
that she tries to hide by jacking of
goddamn [ __ ] ass in the air two eye
level
no girls would've bang that guy but what
did he do he came in there he came in
there and he [ __ ] sang a song and he
took over your [ __ ] City the way a
bunch of people from other states that
you [ __ ] New Yorkers look down on we
come in there all the time we come in
there and we blow away half the [ __ ]
talent in New York because you guys are
standing there eating a slice of pizza
looking at the [ __ ] Empire State
Building going oh it's open all night
you're not doing [ __ ] you don't have a
big stage you have a sorry-ass [ __ ]
NBA team you know this out dumb the
[ __ ] Knicks are Isiah Thomas
there was a league called the CBA that
did fine for like thirty [ __ ] years
and then what's-his-face Isiah Tomic
Thomas became president of the league
and in like three four years I don't
have the [ __ ] stats I don't know five
years it went out of business
okay I'm not talking about you know a
winning franchise went to a losing
franchise I'm not talking about a
franchise that existed in a city had to
move I'm not even saying the franchise
folded I'm talking about an entire
[ __ ] league he got it the controls he
pushed the yoke forward and just flew
this [ __ ] right into the goddamn ground
all right and like Bugs Bunny he stepped
out right before it hit the ground
before any of it got on him and then the
Knicks go yet that's our guy
that's the guy we're gonna get to run
the [ __ ] NBA franchise the guy who
[ __ ] flew bootleg NBA into the
goddamn ground that's the [ __ ] dude
see that's why the LeBron didn't come
now cuz he's afraid of the big stage you
wanted who was afraid of the big stage
Jeff Weaver Jeff Weaver was afraid of
the big stage okay but LeBron James is
not afraid of the big at the big stage
okay
he could [ __ ] put his nuts on Jeff
Weaver's chest and hold him down in the
deep end of a [ __ ] pool all right
he's not afraid of [ __ ] Madison
Square Garden and I also thought it was
really [ __ ] ironic that of the three
emails that I read by New Yorkers which
I'm now judging all of them they were
going like you know Miami that's Dwyane
Wade's town if he goes down there and
wins a championship there nobody's gonna
respect him can you [ __ ] believe a
New Yorker had the balls to say that
with the [ __ ] pylon team that the
Yankees have been for the last 12
[ __ ] years
every goddamn free agent on the [ __ ]
planet just clinging to Derek Jeter's
leg show me how to do it I want to win
one too huh Roger Clemens that fat
buffalo wing neaten jackass was it hard
up in Toronto Roger
then he [ __ ] comes down there and
jumps in the [ __ ] limo the [ __ ]
balls of these New York fans to sit
there and question somebody piling on
another team to go in a [ __ ]
championship I can't even take it I
think I got a drink some throat koti did
I mention that on this podcast has
already deleted the other one when I was
annoyed with how [ __ ] unfunny I was
where I'm gonna go out on a limb here
and say that the ratings for this in New
York City are gonna be kind of low this
week I got this throat coati which is
great if you stand on stage and you
don't know how to write a joke you have
to scream at jokes or even if you like
to call your girlfriend a [ __ ] at the
top of your lungs you know you ever do
that and then the next day you want to
do it again but your throat is too tore
up you can't do it well get organic
throat cote everybody you could call
your girl a [ __ ] seven days a week 365
anyone who isn't from America or I guess
you know Americans who are also into
soccer
and then I trashed a giant media market
see right there bill that's why New York
is such the big stage because it's one
of the biggest media markets you know
the [ __ ] could for you how pathetic
are you [ __ ] teams that you gotta
bring up the level of media in your city
the level of media give me a [ __ ]
break two championship banners 1970
[ __ ] three do you know in 1973 the
Chevy Vega was considered a sports car
and if you go on the game show network
people lose their [ __ ] minds about
that car
you know you can win and then they open
the curtain a brand new Chevy Vega and
these people with their [ __ ] big Greg
Greg Brady [ __ ] belt buckles and
their [ __ ] uh who's that dude from
knocked up
even reportedly there seth rogen [ __ ]
afros go absolutely [ __ ] apeshit over
a Chevy Vega that's when you guys want
it last people from our dying of old
[ __ ] age on that team who do you have
on that - who are the [ __ ] the Knicks
the greats
who do you got Bill Bradley daddy became
a senator and then he [ __ ] died this
is what it is you want to get down to
brass tacks here what's really bugging
me is in Boston we only have four sports
teams okay we're playing a [ __ ] you
know we got one one bullet in the
chamber and those [ __ ] down there in
New York that doubled down in two out of
the four [ __ ] sports every year the
split and [ __ ] aces in two different
sports
so they pad their stats with
championships but I respect the Yankees
the Yankees are the greatest franchise
in all four sports they got the [ __ ]
championships you have to respect it
they got him and I would never ever try
to act like somebody was afraid to play
in Boston
because of the media or whatever the
[ __ ] that you know or call it the big
stage in Boston all right I would never
do that out of respect for the [ __ ]
Yankees the fact that they have 20 more
[ __ ] Championships than we do okay so
give me the [ __ ] respect that I
deserve as a Boston Celtic fan that we
have 15 more [ __ ] NBA championships
than you do [ __ ] idiots
the big stage I'm so sick of these fat
man titted [ __ ] with their [ __ ]
game worn jerseys and they yell [ __ ] at
players on the field and they think that
they're intimidating them you know like
the fact that you got a D up Kobe Bryant
that you know that night isn't enough to
make you nervous no it's the fat [ __ ]
with the shaved head and [ __ ] row 58g
who sues chanting airball and he they
don't care then even [ __ ] hear it
they don't even hear it LeBron James is
not afraid to go into New York he wanted
to win all right
that's why the [ __ ] he went to Miami but
uh you know and I would really love in
and this is the deal if if the [ __ ]
Lakers didn't exist with their stupid
t-shirts claiming that the Los Angeles
Lakers have [ __ ] 16 because that's
what the t-shirt says it says Los
Angeles Lakers 16 championships not Los
Angeles / Minneapolis Lakers so now I
have to become a Miami Heat fan I really
do but just for the record dude I don't
like any of this [ __ ] I didn't like the
2008 Boston Celtics I didn't like that
either
where you just go out and just everybody
piles on one team I don't [ __ ] like
it I don't like this age of the super
teams it's you know I don't even that's
not know what it is anymore it's like
it's like it's sports are becoming like
what wreath retail stores have become
they're all like these super stores now
there's not like just a regular hardware
store that example I use every podcast
it's always a hardware store with me a
[ __ ] one-trick pony
it's all [ __ ] it's all Walmart's now
home
depos best buys all of that type of [ __ ]
and I don't know it's not the same kind
of pride like that that you had back in
the day when you watched red Arabic get
some unknown Center from Golden State
you know Robert Parish who the [ __ ] knew
who he was before he came to the Celtics
and he goes after Kevin McHale wasn't a
highly touted draft pick and then Larry
Bird he works on for like three [ __ ]
years and gets him to come to the
Celtics like that was some interesting
[ __ ] but nowadays when you got [ __ ] like
Kevin McHale a former Celtic is working
for the Grizzlies and he gives the
[ __ ] Celtics Kevin Garnett for
nothing for nothing
decimates an entire [ __ ] franchise
the same way Jerry West is [ __ ]
working from Memphis and gives the
[ __ ] Lakers Pau Gasol for nothing I
mean is it I don't know I don't [ __ ]
know and the fact that these [ __ ]
Knick fans are sitting there talking
about that guy piling on as the goddamn
Yankees are in negotiations to try to
get Cliff Lee like they don't have
enough with [ __ ] Sabathia AJ Burnett
Mariano Rivera [ __ ] Alex Rodriguez al
[ __ ] to share all those guys I love
all the names of fading away cuz I don't
even watch baseball anymore it's such a
[ __ ] stupid goddamn sport
dude if the Yankees got Cliff Lee you
might as well just mail them the trophy
you know and I'm this is what it is I
don't know if I'm just this crabby old
man I'm really trying to find the art in
signing all these free agents because it
just seems to me like whoever has the
most [ __ ] money will eventually get
most of the best guys you know
occasionally you lose out on a guy
occasionally a Cliff Lee will go to the
Rangers you know
or somebody will pick the [ __ ] angels
or maybe they'll go to the [ __ ] Red
Sox or something like that but generally
speaking you start with the [ __ ]
Yankees and then it just goes down I
don't know I just doesn't seem like
there's any [ __ ] skill I just been of
a five I'm you know it is I'm on my
[ __ ] period this week half hour
ragging about that [ __ ] let's get to uh
let's key let's just totally [ __ ]
make a left turn here and somebody asked
me some for some advice this week
all right here we go this is this is now
this is a quote this is a situation that
I think a lot of people let all embrace
can deal with let's see here hey Bill
huge fan love you comedy but they hope
this won't get too long
it starts with one of my good friends
going out with this girl they went out
for a body of right off the bat you know
you can't you tell where this is going
this story starts with one of my good
friends going out with this girl they
went out for about a year or two on our
on and off come on bill focus here just
try to read this smoothly alright start
over it starts with one of my good
friends going out with this girl they
went out for about a year or two on and
off still though even when they were
together they were never really good in
quotes here we go
they fought basically all the time and
just didn't seem right for each other
oh gee you know where this is going
during the early stages of their
relationship my friend thought I had a
thing for her oh she's she is a
good-looking girl she is a good-looking
girl and I was friends with her before
they even got together dude you are so
justifying what the [ __ ] you either did
or about ready to do I love it they
weren't really good for each other
even when they were together they just
there was something missing I actually
knew her before he did um here we go she
is a good-looking girl and I was friends
with her before they were even together
I admit I might have inadvertently
been a little flirty with her sometimes
oh I'm sorry was I just flirting there
do you have a future at @bp the next
time they pollute an entire Gulf of a
nation that they're not even citizens of
and they need to bring somebody out to
stand behind the podium dude this is
[ __ ] great
I might have inadvertently been a little
flirty with her how the [ __ ] do you even
do that how do you inadvertently flirt
with somebody wow you really look
beautiful in that dress I'll tell you if
you were my girlfriend I have a debit
that I mean wait wait a [ __ ] do you go
with oh I'm sorry I'm sorry that's right
you're not my girlfriend I'm sorry if I
thought you're my girlfriend for a
second what was I thinking Jesus Christ
I'm so embarrassed my face turned red
oh my god I was just inadvertently
flirting with you right then oh Jesus oh
here we go but any goes this is what he
says I might have inadvertently been a
little flirty with her sometimes but
that [ __ ] always happens with a guy and
a girl I think dude the level of guilt
just weighing you down as you're trying
to justify all of this either way I told
him I didn't like her
which was true dude stop lying to
yourself anyways it passed however I
always got this feeling that there was a
there was still an undertone that he
resented me since then yeah probably
because of all the inadvertent flirting
and the fact that you were remoting that
they weren't right for each other
but anyways let's let's let's fast
forward as he says fast forward now
they've been broken up for at least a
year and don't talk she says he randomly
text her Texas her texter Jesus Christ I
can't even [ __ ] read she says he
randomly texts her but that she doesn't
ever answer him but regardless of that
now this girl likes me what oh my god I
didn't see that coming wait a minute
anyways but she actually likes me and
basically says she wants to [ __ ] my
voice just cracked in the perfect says
she wants to [ __ ] am I getting excited I
need some more throat code here and
basically says she wanted to fall she
tells me stuff like she wishes she went
out with me instead of him to begin with
now I do all right with girls but I
don't have them lining up or anything
so I'm not trying to let a virtual
sure thing passed me by oh my god and
this is when it's getting Jerry Springer
here with most guys I don't I feel like
they'd not care if I went for it or at
least understand why I did did you
realize what you're saying I think most
guys wouldn't care if their best friend
went out and banged their [ __ ]
ex-girlfriend within a year of them
going out I think that they'd understand
so anyways he goes I think most guys
won't understand but this buddy of mine
is a little nuts and it's also a
situation where he's the type of guy
that if he were in my position he'd do
the same thing afterward you're just
justifying you don't even need my advice
you're gonna do it my other friend who
knows the whole situation says I should
but others I've talked to about it say I
shouldn't the last I talked to her she
said she wanted to hang out just me and
her and that I should let her know when
I want to
all right I guess this thing's getting
kind of long I have one question do I
have any justification and [ __ ] this
girl and two if I do would you say I
should go through with it
okay all right sir there there's just
there's just a ton of [ __ ] going on here
okay right off the bat you have to be
honest with yourself
all right you weren't inadvertently
flirting with this girl you actually
probably liked this girl before this guy
even got with her or maybe the fact that
you the guy your friend got worth their
names banging her made you all of a
sudden interested in her see I don't
know you as a person you could be a very
sadistic human being actually I'm gonna
go on a limb and say you're not because
the fact that you actually give a [ __ ]
enough to write me and ask whether you
should do this that means you actually
have some sort of guilt about it so you
won't get off on banging your [ __ ]
best friend's ex-girlfriend dude there's
a lot of [ __ ] here that could blow up in
your face okay in a perfect world
all right you're a man and you say you
know what that's not gonna be worth the
the the blowback it's not gonna be worth
the [ __ ] damage that I'm gonna do
this guy's my best friend
I don't even though he would do it to me
I'm not gonna do it to him and then I
also need to stop being friends with
this guy because anybody who would go
out and [ __ ] my ex-girlfriend within a
year it's not truly a friend I need to
get better friends but despite all that
I'm still not gonna do what the [ __ ] he
would have done just because he would
have done it to me and you just walk
away from the situation and you go out
and you chat up some other [ __ ] brats
that's that is like if you want to be
knighted someday by one of those [ __ ]
broads over there and in the castle in
England you know if you want to go over
there with surf surf Phil Collins
looking on and get knighted that's what
the [ __ ] you do but if you're gonna bang
this broad
you've already [ __ ] up okay [ __ ]
you
as friends ex-girlfriend it's like
committing a murder you want as few
people involved as humanly possible I
learned that on an episode of uninformed
when we had a cop come in and me and my
co-host Joe DeRosa were saying that you
know we were trying to come up with how
to commit the perfect murder and I
remember said ok I'd get me and a buddy
of mine he goes right there you [ __ ]
up right there you [ __ ] up he goes the
more people you bring in the bigger
chance you have of getting caught you
know because you're not gonna rat
yourself out but the other guy if he
gets scared might go down to the police
station and try to cop a plea all right
that's the same [ __ ] with this if you're
gonna [ __ ] your best friend's girl
ex-girlfriend you don't go around and
ask other friends going dude should I do
it you don't and you already did all
right and then the other side of it is I
don't know how the two of these people
broke up but
hell hath no fury like a woman scorned
and for all you know this chick might be
a [ __ ] psycho alright I mean I think
it's a good thing that he's texting her
and not the other way around and that
she is not texting him back granted
you're taking her word for it that
that's what the situation is now for all
you know it's the reverse and if it is
the reverse she wants some sort of
vengeance which means she goes out and
bangs his best friend and then lo and
behold feels guilty the next day and
then has to tell him alright just to let
you know that is on the [ __ ] table if
you really want to know whether or not
you want a jerk if you want a forger --k
if you want to [ __ ] I get ahead of
myself here if you want to [ __ ] this
girl or not just go jerk off to her and
after you're done if you still want to
bang her you want to bang her and then
just [ __ ] man up and deal with the
[ __ ] consequences of it and go out
and bang her cuz who gives a [ __ ] as
someday you're gonna be 80 and who gives
a [ __ ] you know
that if you actually have feelings for
this girl that's a hole then you should
definitely do it if you actually feel
like this girl could be the girl that
you're gonna spend your life with then I
would definitely say go for it knowing
full well that your friendship with this
other guy is is gonna end I don't know
so dude if you know what it's it's
[ __ ] on you you know if you ask me
what I do it yeah I would have back in
the day I would have but now that I'm an
older wiser man I wouldn't I would just
[ __ ] rub one out to her and then be
afterwards going ah thank God I didn't
[ __ ] do that thank God I didn't do
that and I was I would also [ __ ] not
hang out with the other guy cuz any guy
friend of mine that would [ __ ] an
ex-girlfriend of mine within a [ __ ]
year I I wouldn't want to be friends
with even though I just described all of
my friends dude I don't know what to
tell you I don't know what to tell you
you probably shouldn't do it you should
pray you shouldn't dude you shouldn't
you should go out and go [ __ ] bang
somebody else you shouldn't alright but
I feel like a hypocrite because I would
I would but then again I'm also a
[ __ ] 42 year old guy who never got
married so what so you're listening to a
complete [ __ ] scumbag here so Jesus
Christ this is why I don't have a
[ __ ] advice show you know because in
my attempt to be honest I I get I tell
you both things do it don't do it I
would but you shouldn't have a nice day
you know what let's let's go to the
listeners I would love to hear from the
women because they're gonna have on both
sides they're gonna have like you
shouldn't yeah that's your friend and
then they're also gonna be mad on some
level like why did guys feel like they
own somebody just cuz they used to go
out with them because we're territorial
we're territorial that way and you have
to understand that whoever you've banged
in your life is a female for the rest of
your life that pussy's not yours anymore
it belongs to him and you can say it's
yours it isn't because he [ __ ] it
[Laughter]
all right you know what I feel like you
know there wasn't enough ignorance on
this podcast so I feel like I had to
just say something stupid like that but
that'sthat's how guys work and I didn't
even ask you this is your best friend is
he bigger than you are physically can he
beat you down
does he take jujitsu classes um has he
ever had any murderous thoughts that he
sort of divulged to you in a you know a
night of drinking too many tequila shots
and you see an A&E darker side of him
you know there's there's a whole bunch
of [ __ ] ah this is what you gotta do
this is what you gotta do go out and get
yourself a [ __ ] pimp hat alright and
this is what you have to do you got to
go to this girl and you just got to lay
it on the [ __ ] table that's what you
got to do you just got to be honest with
her and just say look sweetheart I have
wanted to [ __ ] you since 2006 you don't
say that
but basically you finish your way into
that you got to tell her that you've
wanted to hook up with her and the only
reason why you didn't
this is the deal this is
alright well we had a little technical
difficulty there
I left you hanging sorry about that the
batteries just died I was right in the
middle of trying to tell this dude how
we could go out and bang this girl now I
got a [ __ ] stick this into the
goddamn girl GarageBand and splice it
together which I already did at this
point so why even [ __ ] about it when
you listen to this [ __ ] thing alright
let me wrap this goddamn podcast up by
telling this kid how to go out and [ __ ]
his best friend's ex-girlfriend alright
this is what you do you got it you got
to have a talk with this girl before you
do it don't just go over there and just
[ __ ] sneak over there you know with
this nervous excitement [ __ ] rail
this girl bust you nut and then realize
oh my god
I have no [ __ ] feelings for this girl
and then you know risking that she'll
then you know be resentful all the
[ __ ] I said on the first [ __ ]
installment of this goddamn podcast this
is what you gotta do you gotta [ __ ]
get everything out in the open all right
and [ __ ] let her convince you that
it's the right [ __ ] thing to do and
get her to say that she ain't gonna say
[ __ ] alright get her to say that and
when she says she's not gonna say [ __ ]
you have to read her alright
like a [ __ ] seasoned goddamn pro you
know the 27 [ __ ] pantomimes are lying
whatever that [ __ ] goddamn movie was
true romance you got a look at her and
you you have to you have to make a
[ __ ] assessment if this girl can keep
her [ __ ] mouth shut
by presenting these scenarios you got
look I'm gonna get worried that tomorrow
what if you're gonna wake up feeling
guilty and then you have to confess to
him you know I'm not gonna feel I'm not
gonna feel guilty yeah you are you just
[ __ ] I don't know I'm really giving
you [ __ ] advice dude I'm trying to give
you a [ __ ] scumbag way to go out and
go do this [ __ ] just like I don't know
I'm [ __ ] bad at this man I have to be
in the moment then what the [ __ ] dirtbag
goddamn thing would I be saying all
right this is what you do you don't go
over or [ __ ] this is what you do
don't go over a goddamn place see this
is the hard thing now you got to go out
you got a meter in public okay so
there's no sexual [ __ ] intention that
you can act on all right so your dick
won't be like dude she's fine she's not
lying she's not lying she's going to be
cool what you have to do is
you gotta meet in a public place where
then people can see you see - this is
just it's just a [ __ ] it's a it's a
tough one tell you what - it if you can
actually [ __ ] pull this off why don't
you write me back and tell ya tell me
how you how the [ __ ] you did it
I remember a long time ago I was in the
beginning of a relationship and I was
banging this still banging this other
psycho on the side and like a dirtbag
you know and I remember there was going
to be a point where the two of them were
gonna be at the same [ __ ] place
so I just dealt with it but was it
before we hooked up I just said look you
gotta be honest with you this girl I'm
coming down with we're new I'm starting
to have feelings for her all right
I told her that I cleaned up everything
on the side which I haven't with you so
I need you to not act weird when I
[ __ ] come down there if I don't you
know if I'm not saying hello to you okay
that was before I hooked up with her
she's like fine fine then she went down
there and then she did that cool because
in her head she's probably holding out
like maybe if I had cool he'll see how
[ __ ] cool I am and then I want to be
with me and not this other [ __ ] and
meanwhile I [ __ ] got away with it and
you know what a part of me died another
[ __ ] chunk of my soul came out it's a
dirty [ __ ] game it's a dirty goddamn
game I'm a piece of [ __ ] don't [ __ ]
listen to me all right what else do we
got this week oh by the way dude now
that I talked about it for 10 [ __ ]
minutes
you got you got to write a spec and let
us know what happened all right
you know I realize this might be like
one of those stupid Hollywood movies and
then I realized that's not the person I
wanted to be dude if you do that I don't
want to [ __ ] hear it but if you don't
if you do the dirty [ __ ] I want to
hear about it would I be the worst
[ __ ] life coach ever all right here's
a segment corporate [ __ ] a bill for
someone who flies as much as you do can
you take a shot at explaining the logic
behind why a one-way ticket almost cost
more than a roundtrip for a domestic for
domestic flights maybe this isn't a
problem however I'm flying from you're
from Europe at the end of the month on a
one-way ticket and it costs one and a
half times more than a round-trip ticket
and I immediately said well why don't
you buy the roundtrip ticket and he
addresses this immediately and says and
if the airline company can prove that I
purchased a round-trip ticket it with
the intent of not using the return for
the flight they can legally charge for
the price difference between the fares
what the [ __ ] is this normal business
practice I hate to tell you it but it is
because that's how corrupt our [ __ ]
government is that's how powerful
corporations are around the [ __ ]
world they do whatever that whatever
they want to do and they have this thing
where every quarter they have to show a
profit all right actually they have to
show more of a profit than the previous
quarter they can't even just have the
same amount of profit it's not enough
and basically they've legally run out of
ways to create revenue streams so what
they're doing now is they're just
stealing they're stealing from people
all right if you have a one-way ticket
that means you're going home or you're
starting a new life and you want to get
the [ __ ] out of where you're at so
that's why they know that they can
charge you a ton of [ __ ] money all
right
and then well what somebody's around
trip ticket then we'll [ __ ] we'll
just write this little bill here and
we'll have the senator who we [ __ ]
paid for his goddamn campaign help push
it through isn't that how it works they
just call this senator I don't know
anything ya know it's a piece of [ __ ]
thing so what you got to do is you have
to vandalize the airplane alright do
something to vandalize the [ __ ]
airplane yeah I don't even do that
because all they're going to do is just
pass that expense on to us
this is what you have to do you have to
find out who it is that came up with
that who created that who was who was
the lobbyist who pushed that thing
through how that somehow became legal
you got to find out where they live and
then you just got it you got a tail them
the whole [ __ ] week get their
patterns down figure out when they go to
the goddamn gym all right borrow a pair
of pantyhose from your [ __ ]
girlfriend put it over your head
hide in some shrubs and when that dude
comes walking out of the gym with that
[ __ ] towel around his neck you just
blast them right in the face and then
you [ __ ] choke them with it your
choke them your mushas facing to the
mulch
and you'll be like to ask for that
one-way ticket from [ __ ] holid back
to the state you [ __ ] and then you're
getting your [ __ ] Ford Festiva and
you drive away that's the only way to
get back at him and and if you do that
I'll give you a free DVD underrated
overrated for the week underrated the
movie waiting it's all about the world
of restaurant waiters cooks it cetera
it's funny honest and quite gross I
imagine it is because I've worked in a
couple of [ __ ] restaurants and the
[ __ ] that goes on you know the [ __ ] that
you'll do when you're not cooking for a
family member is really it's staggering
I'll leave it at that
overrated um this is pretty bitter but
anyways when you watch the special
features on a DVD and there's always the
making of feature far too many of these
features including the movie waiting
that I just recommended have the actors
in the director's jokingly calling
others on the film useless awful amateur
amateurish etc they'll talk about how
the whole film is a disaster and we'll
and we'll go straight to video get it
they don't really mean it they're joking
around lol lol see I told you it was a
bitter one yeah I guess you know I kind
understand me how many times can you
just sit there and go Ashton Kutcher was
absolutely brilliant in madam of the
butterfly or the butterfly effect
whatever the [ __ ] it was called that
scene his reaction here is right up with
Bruce Willis in die hard part 3 when he
turns around and looks at the green
screen and pretends to be looking at a
jumbo jet it was absolutely some of the
best act I mean how long could you
listen to that so they got to make fun
of themselves I would go with arrogance
I would just talk about my scenes and
how [ __ ] amazing I am while I was
pointing out the dumb [ __ ] that I did it
in YouTube videos for the week and do
that I I'm gonna tell you man I think
I'm recommended or at least the bliss
iners of my podcast will recommend some
of the funniest and best [ __ ] YouTube
videos out there how great were those
YouTube videos last week you know all
right here's one
duckface song
search duck face song like quack quack
duck face song this is an amazing one
search fake yo-yo trickster Fool's every
TV station everywhere I mean granted it
could have been shorter but fake yo-yo
trickster fools every TV station every
way this is hilarious this guy goes on
and he claims to be a yo-yo champion and
he actually sucks at it and he talks all
this [ __ ] and then he goes on there and
he can't pull off any tricks and he just
stands there and the leaves the Morning
News guy with the awkwardness of him
completely failing and not handling the
failing and just leaving it in the lap
of the reporter and it's it's [ __ ]
awesome ah here's one for all you kids
and I'm gonna use the young kid where
this one is epic
this one isn't on YouTube this is how
cutting-edge the Monday morning podcast
is go to www.bravotv.com
[Music]
and the name of the song is hammer smash
face and if you don't already know that
song I suggest you listen to it first
listen to Cannibal Corpse hammer smashed
face for as long as you can unless your
death metal fan and then you'll love it
or a fan of comedy and then go to search
Cannibal Corpse hammer smashed face
smash face disney radio version some
[ __ ] genius out there basically you
know I guess deaf metals a lot of like I
don't know the darker chords and he
turned him all plays the same chord but
in a major chord which are the happier
once and then he sings the song with the
same lyrics it's [ __ ] great and that
is it you know what I didn't bring up my
sides from front hyping the month the
mmm podcast calm
is in all of this LeBron [ __ ] I didn't
really bring up like the fans of [ __ ]
Cleveland and yet another [ __ ] blow
that those people have to take I mean
that just it's brutal between the
industry leaving that town and then all
you know
CC Sabathia he went end up going to New
York Manny Ramirez went to Boston Jim
Thome went to Philly I mean they had the
team and now they finally get like
[ __ ] arguably I would say the next
Kobe level player he's got a way to go
but the next Kobe level player player
and LeBron James gave him a reason to go
to the downtown area it sucks it sucks
because downtown Cleveland if you really
look at the buildings if you can look
past this scary homeless people and
really look at the buildings it's
beautiful it's just that you know
getting back to these corporate [ __ ]
they just pulled up stakes and they left
because they were sick of paying people
a fair wage and they were sick of having
to pay for health insurance and they
wanted to have some eight-year-old go
put the [ __ ] grill on a goddamn
[ __ ] Caprice Classic I don't [ __ ]
know same thing with Detroit those all
those cities Buffalo all of them if you
look at them the buildings they're vert
they're beautiful cities and you can see
what they used to be and it's it's a
[ __ ] shame I don't know I don't know
how to bring them back you know by
American which is why I'm gonna get the
[ __ ] Challenger okay and if I find
out that that's actually put together
down in [ __ ] Honduras I'm gonna be
[ __ ] pissed
all right now challenge
is dodged no put together in [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] thing is I'm gonna
learn Spanish goddamn it and I'm gonna
have to podcasts I'll have one in
[ __ ] on glaze and one in [ __ ]
espanol would that be great then I could
phone that I could actually trash people
in their native language about how much
soccer is [ __ ] boring alright that is
that's the podcast for this week once
again thanks for everybody contributing
please visit the MM podcast.com if you
if you don't I searched YouTube it's a
[ __ ] pain in the ass or then you got
to go to why everything is terrible calm
if you just want them all in a night
nice neat little package like those
little [ __ ] things you know when you
when your girl's got a birthday and you
just go down to the spine you get her
little [ __ ] fancy soaps and
everything we got YouTube videos package
just like that with a nice little bow on
them and all the references that I make
like Bill Bradley and all that [ __ ]
go to the mm podcast.com I'm gonna be at
the Montreal Comedy Festival this week
I'll be doing David Letterman next week
but that's neither here nor there
because I'll be doing a podcast next
Monday before I tape it anyway so I can
talk to you guys about what it's like to
be sitting around the day of doing a
David Letterman spot that is it god
bless you I'll talk to you later
[Music]
Thanks
became heart
[Music]
and - great
you're out
[Music]
you